una amigdalectomía es la extirpación
quirúrgica de las amígdalas para latinas
dos estructuras ubicadas en ambos lados
de la parte posterior de la garganta
normalmente las amígdalas tienen la
función de evitar las infecciones al
ayudar en la destrucción de las
bacterias nocivas y otros gérmenes que
ingresan al organismo a través de la
nariz y boca las adenoides ubicadas
debajo y detrás del paladar blando
tienen una función similar generalmente
las amígdalas se agrandan e inflaman
cuando combaten una infección esta
afección se denomina amigdalitis
la amigdalitis puede estar relacionada
con la fiebre el dolor de garganta la
deglución dolorosa y la hinchazón de los
ganglios linfáticos de la parte frontal
del cuello
se diagnostica más comúnmente en los
niños pero también se puede observar en
algunos adultos aunque existe una
cantidad de indicaciones para la
amigdalectomía la más común es la
amigdalitis recurrente o crónica la
inflamación crónica de las adenoides por
lo general debido a alergias puede
provocar el bloqueo de las trompas de
eustaquio aumentando el riesgo de
contraer infecciones del oído medio y la
pérdida auditiva relacionada una
adenoidectomía es la extirpación
quirúrgica de las adenoides generalmente
las amigdalectomías y las adenoidectomía
se realizan al mismo tiempo cuando llega
al hospital para someterse al
procedimiento se le colocará una vía
intravenosa y es posible que se les
suministre un sedante para ayudarlo a
relajarse en la mayoría de los
procedimientos se utiliza anestesia
general por lo tanto estará dormido todo
el tiempo que dure la operación se
insertará temporalmente un tubo
respiratorio por la boca y en la
garganta para ayudarlo a respirar
durante la operación las amigdalectomías
y las adenoidectomía pocas veces se
realizan con anestesia local en adultos
y nunca en niños
durante la amigdalectomía el cirujano
utilizará un retractor especial para
mantener la boca del paciente abierta y
un depresor de lengua para garantizar
una vista despejada de las amígdalas
el cirujano sujetará una amígdala por
vez con los fórceps de amígdalas
la desprenderá del tejido que la rodea
y le extirpara con un lazo corredizo o
una pinza prensada de amígdalas
y la electro que autorización a las
pinzas y los lazos detendrán cualquier
sangrado que se produzca en la zona
donde se extirparon las amígdalas
generalmente esta área cicatriza
naturalmente sin puntos el procedimiento
para una adenoidectomía es muy similar
al de una amigdalectomía por lo general
ambos procedimientos se pueden realizar
en 20 a 60 minutos
después de la operación se lo llevará a
una sala de recuperación hasta que se
desaparezcan los efectos de la anestesia
lo que por lo general tarda entre 8 y 10
horas es normal que los pacientes de una
amigdalectomía regresen a su hogar el
mismo día del procedimiento